[Music]
it was approaching summer and Boris
Johnson was still prime minister six
months feels a long time ago now amid
winter weather and Christmas preparation
inflation interest rates and costs are
all up
hey Laura it's Dan here from Sky News
so the last time that we caught up with
Lara she told us she's just canceled her
direct debits for her gas and
electricity she simply couldn't afford
it anymore of course since then all the
bills have gone up again
it's only just been reinstated this
month I'm now
nearly 600 pound in arrears
the energy support payments have helped
but the fact is Lara is now in debt it
is frightening because I don't see any
like at the end of the tunnel of that
bill my arrears is getting more and more
and I just feel I can't pay it
since we last came to Plymouth a new
multi-agency cost of living task force
has been set up it's needed the council
says because requests for financial help
are up 235 percent what is interesting
is that we're seeing that increase in
Wards the ordinarily don't contact them
so my ward in particular is in a more
affluent part of the city but the
increase has been seen there so that's
definitely something that we're going to
have to watch going forward do you want
to keep hold of these we've got a few
radiators that need doing it it's part
of the new task force age UK Plymouth is
offering over 50s a free check on how
they can reduce their home bills they've
run out of kits because demand is so
high
veterans Ian and Annette don't get any
benefits and feel that those in the
middle aren't getting enough support
you're the ones that then don't get any
extra help and that money is then being
chomped up either with fuel for your car
the food costs more the energy bills
costs more
um
and yeah it's tough
down at the harbor things aren't much
better Chris after 45 years fishing
Chris is now trying to sell his boat but
thinks the tight margins and high costs
are making the Next Generation think
twice fuel used to be sort of five to
ten percent of your gross now it's 25 to
30 you know the boys are looking we're
looking at one another you know we can't
this this won't go out to sea for
nothing we've got to catch fish
looking back six months there's no
denying that things have got tougher in
Plymouth but the community rallies for
is likely to be an even harder winter
Dan Whitehead Sky News in Plymouth